you look at tate it's not very clear to  me as to like why he got taken off all  these two no dude but i spoke to him the  day that it happened because i had  called him immediately i was like dude  like that just happened it's important  for people to understand this because he  didn't post anything the violated  policies you know the policy they banned  him under  was the dangerous individuals or  organizations why does this policy exist  this policy exists so that the  plan can't have an official instagram  page this this exists so i'll  could not be putting out recruitment  videos on on youtube etc they've  essentially thrown him in that same  category with the worst like actual  terrorists actual murderers actual  genocidal maniacs some of the most  dangerous words being used these days  are dangerous  safety  harm and harmful